honestly if a Muslim family moved next
door to you you would be the happiest
person in the world first of all the
chances of your kids getting in trouble
just went way down
okay went way down because the Muslim
community has the lowest crime rate the
highest entrepreneurship the highest
educational attainment for women in the
country they are the model American
community and so when you have people
who are now afraid to come here now
starting to happen you have geniuses who
are from Pakistan who are from Indonesia
whose dude now that I don't know if I'm
safe here that becomes an economic
problem for the minute for America long
term so that we're starting to do stuff
here that doesn't make good sense for
that for what has made us great so far
he's been a real real show salamualikum'
I just met my brother William so I'm
like a warrior
what ekam saranam let's go hey what a
country how you guys doing hundred
lights always exciting to me people who
have found this beautiful way of life
and we want to pick their brains to see
why why why did they accept Islam why
did you accept some
well it was a petrol disparity truth
looking for you know the oneness of God
the who was our Creator what is our
purpose who was our Lord and you know it
took half my life but it came to
fruition who empty lot who you know
struggle this is why like you were
speaking earlier about you know and the
other brother was about struggles and
you know how we have to look at this is
the test from Allah that this is this is
what makes us who we are we're supposed
to accept it
struggle through it if it was easy we
wouldn't be muscling right you know this
is what Allah has for us to test us we
have to sow the seeds for the action all
right
don't tell me William there's so many
there's so much misinformation and
there's so much dirt put over Islam but
many people like yourself when they dig
a little bit they find the treasure so
for people who are out there they see
you white American they hear the word
law they think of Psalms is something so
foreign and strangest for the other but
then they see an American they see
someone he's he's a practicing Muslim
you know what do you have to say for
those people who are scared they think
that Islam is like the boogeyman come in
and get you well this is what I usually
tell people cuz that I do a hundred I've
been blessed to be able as an American
to be able to reach out speak to my
fellow Americans the same culture is
that I told them most Muslims are
Americans that much of our culture and
history here in America has Muslims have
always been there Islam has always been
part of it founding fathers had of Quran
knew about Islam
understood you know the justice of the
laws how the Ottoman Caliphate operated
at that time they had contacts Kingdom
of Morocco was the first country to
wreck
the United States v I remember a lot of
many of our African brothers and sisters
who came for hundreds of years against
their will or Muslims some of them were
allowed to maintain their Deen and we
have these these stories and these
narratives preserved so Aslam has always
been here so it's been part of it and so
we're as much of the fabric of this
country in this history you know and I'd
like to trace it back being from Detroit
if you look at the auto industry you
know economists and historians will say
this is what built the the the middle
class here in the 20th century was the
auto industry well what was the big part
of the auto industry
you know Detroit was the mecca of it
right Arab Americans Muslim and
Christian that was the back that was
that was my grandfather did when he came
here over 100 years ago he worked on the
Ford assembly line and then like many
Lebanese he went to started his own
business entrepreneurship we helped
build this country so we've just as much
as any other group and so you know and I
let people know we're not a bunch of
weird foreigners
everyday people to say everybody else
I'm sure they have these same struggles
we got first generation second
generation third generation fifth
generation again that african-american
brothers and sisters how many
generations do they go back
they discover it look for their identity
and they find out you know what I'm a
Muslim - my people work and are many
people they get you know when you start
to explain like they hear this word law
you know you tell him that look Jesus he
spoke Aramaic he would say AHA Muslim is
simply one like in the Lord's Prayer is
it
o our Father who art in heaven hallowed
be thy name thy will be done and unless
some Alamosa
someone who submitted to a little god so
you didn't do nothin weird and
constrained you submitted yourself like
Jesus to the Creator tell me what is one
of the major misconceptions that people
have but you come across when you're you
know sharing the message what's one of
the the number
things that people fear or they
misunderstand about a snail in your
experience well it's kind of changed
never first it was you know the
misconception that we don't have Jesus
we do have Jesus and that's one of the
things that was the guiding factor for
me was I can still love Jesus and I have
to love Jesus as a Muslim so though this
still exists the understanding about
Mary and Jesus are they through Salama
on both of them but also the the
intention they think there's an agenda
that our agenda is to establish control
over people from a top-down way this is
obviously not correct this is not the
Manhattan of the Prophet he and he
emboldened people with faith this is
what Allah gave him the earliest
revelations were about Iman and
accountability and our place with the
Creator that's what the early and this
is what we are supposed to do were
supposed to be benefiting mankind in our
society so this is the the
misconceptions and we've got to do our
part physically to show because the
Christians and the Jews are cousins of
yours-- Jews have been doing it for a
long time in doing social justice work
we have to follow in the footsteps of
our cousins more we really got to get
out there and that's the biggest
misconception and you know one
journalist said it great I'm sorry I'm
taking a lot of time but I want to put
it out the Van Jones set a very good
thing then I always say he mimics what I
say and he's not even Muslim Anisa
honestly if a Muslim family moved next
door to you you would be the happiest
person in the world first of all the
chances of your kids getting in trouble
just went way down
okay went way down because the Muslim
community has the lowest crime rate the
highest entrepreneurship the highest
educational attainment for women in the
country they are the model American
community and so when you have people
who are now afraid to come here not
starting to happen you have geniuses who
are from Pakistan who are from Indonesia
who dude now that I don't know if I'm
safe here that becomes an economic
problem for the event for America long
term so that we're starting to do stuff
here that doesn't make good sense for
what has made us great so far the best
people you wanted your neighbor are
Muslims these are the people you want as
your neighbor
and he gave all the reasons why these
are the people with you know the highest
income less crime statistically and and
the people who contribute the most to
our society is the good practicing
Muslim so when people ask me the
question the biggest fun you know
question that they have misconception
fundamental fundamentalist Islam they
hear this this word fundamental and I
said that's where you get it wrong this
is where our society has has
misinterpreted that word for Christians
and Jews and Muslims at any faith if you
observed the fundamental principles then
you're supposed to be a good person
you're supposed to not be a judgmental
person and it you know a negative person
you're supposed to be a positive
contributing loving loving caring kind
person so that's what's a fundamentalist
that's a good thing that's a good thing
and those who call themselves
fundamentalist on our judgmental and
hateful they got it wrong they got it
wrong whatever faith they are that's
amazing you know to see people like
yourself who are searching for purpose
you know
and had an open heart you think that's
one of the key you know ingredients that
you've got to be open you got to be
sincere and you've got to be searching
for the truth it's got it what do you
think is the ingredient to finding
because many people say there's so many
religions they're all the same it's a
crutch I don't need a religion it's just
something that you know control the
masses what do you say to that well in
some ways when you look at how people
have been in fellated people for their
intentions or this is true but that's
why we use the word Deen right you know
this a Deen is ready
Deen is a way of life so when we
understand you know the Quran you know
we have the final element that existed
in all other faiths that Allah has
guidance for us for every aspect of our
life for our physical and the spiritual
nature
see that's what man has gone astray they
forgot the combination of the two so for
those who say that if you understand
that that you get two halves of your
existence that you've got to feed the
new get past all the dogma you'll get
past all that and you just have to ask
that creator for whatever who however
you would define it you know a very good
book to read about tawheed believe it or
not was the Alcoholics Anonymous book
the little blue book because the guy who
wrote that book he said look just pray
to whatever higher power you acknowledge
he's talking fitrah he's talking to he
didn't know anything about Islam I'm
assuming I don't know but if you ask
whatever higher power give me guidance
let me find what it is you want me to do
to guide me along gonna answer that
there are if you're sincere it doesn't
matter and you eventually you'll get
past that negativity about oh it's just
a system it's just bureaucracy it's just
control whatever you do it on your own
you talk to a lot only you are creator
however you want to call that creator
and you're going to get an answer
somewhere you're going to feel that
answer beautiful that makes sense
doesn't it you don't pray to a stick or
stone a bone
a woman a dead person in the gray but
the one who created you reach out say o
my Creator the one who created me the
one who fashioned me guide me what do
you want from me in this life you did it
you're a Muslim now last last closing
piece of advice for those people who are
struggling you know 1 in 10 people they
say antidepressants you have according
to the CDC you have the second leading
cause of death is suicide amongst kids
from the age of 10 to 24 you know so
many people there are more people on
painkillers than on nicotine I mean it's
you know you know that 5% get this we
consume we're 5 percent of the global
population and we consume that we but
people in America they consume 80% of
the cocaine so people are getting doped
up drugged up alcohol is just consuming
them at the pub's you're fed up with it
you tune in to the D show you've been
led to it now but now they have this
trepidation they think like Muslim
terrorists you know I'm gonna join this
weird cult what do you guys say you know
what it if there's something wrong with
it what you know it must be good because
people are trying to attack it so much
and and I can tell you what I see day
and night
we have people weak just because we make
ourself open our Masjid our Center in
Detroit I just have a neon open sign in
front of our door in our bookstore and
people come by all the
and we go out we do the outreach we
don't sit and wait but I honestly at
this point I can sit and wait and people
will come they want to know more so if
it's so bad if it's sort of why is
everyone trying to attack if it's our if
it's so bad then you wouldn't have to
right they wouldn't have to spend
millions and hundreds of millions of
dollars to defame our Deen and defame
our prophet sallallahu alehiwassallaam
in - it was so evident why do they have
to make such an effort that's because
it's good because that's Shaitaan
leading them they choose to follow that
path those who are the righteous Allah
says I'm gonna test you and they're
gonna come after you and Shaitaan is
gonna come after you so yeah this is
this is our actual jihad this is our
struggling so what do I say to you it's
think about it that's a very I was a but
someone put it to me that way I don't
know who it was I was watching and they
said if it was so if it was so bad they
wouldn't have to make do all this work
to make it look bad and when I looked at
myself I looked at the Deen I looked at
the history and looked at the Quran and
the Sunnah and I didn't judge based on
people right because we're still Muslims
were still people we are we have our
problems obviously but when I looked at
the Deen
looked at you know the reality of
humankind of our society studied the
history of so did the Anthropology and I
looked and the Quran answers all of this
throughout time it's eternal it's
eternal
so you know it's evident it's right
there in front of you it's right there
in front of you if it was already if it
was so bad and terrible why is there 200
million plus dollars spent a year and
then some by numerous organizations to
defame and attack our guinea because
it's good because it's from Allah so
it's from the Creator it's just as
righteousness and Shaitaan wants to
destroy that that's why we're in this
fight we're in this fight and it's a
spiritual fight or not thank you thank
you William if you can dig this simple
message of worshipping the creator and
not the creation believing in Jesus is a
Messenger of God who called people to
the same message as all the other
messages including Abraham Moses John
the Baptist
yeah Solomon David the last and final
master Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon all of them calling
people to paradise call him to prepare
for the Day of Judgment warning them
against the Hellfire and to not get
attached to something that's temporary
this world take your share of it but
prepare for the Hereafter
it's a simple message these are the
basic principles and do good be good
make a positive contribution to making
the world a better place you can dig
that you could dig Islam it's simple to
understand call us 1-866-931-6190
in the city of Warren Michigan for 8:09
to look us up give us a call five eight
six five five eight six nine zero zero
we'd love to have you come visit us make
the human connection subscribe if you
haven't already tuned into the D show
every week we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you
so now like please subscribe to the D
show follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]